the Joe Rogan experience but what's
interesting is it's always going to be
dependent upon a single individual
personality that people find appealing
that is huff where we are as a country
yeah I mean and this is and when someone
gets chopped down boy they get chopped
down like Kamala Harris when tulsi
gabbard took her out the hamstrings
that's a wrap baby Tulsi mr. Lucci quit
taking down calm I mean dude she
everybody was saying she's the one she's
gonna run it and talk even thought she
would have a stronger run than she did
and she but did you see how see Tulsi
made her fall apart it's fascinating
she just shrunk into the shadows like
she's you know did you see the last
debate because that was like peak okay
she's done now oh yeah because what was
her main issue it was so hilarious to
watch this her main issue that she
decided I'm going to take a stand on
this and the Trump with Twitter was she
was begging Elizabeth Warren why don't
you support banning Trump from Twitter I
mean we're talking about two different
sets of rules the most powerful man in
the world is violating the - II think
that that was something to hang his hat
on she's surrounded by absolute morons
who are democratic strategies in
Washington DC and they think okay you
have to outflank Elizabeth Warren on her
left on some issue so use this issue and
try to make it seem like you're standing
up for the little guy and you're
standing up for a rules apply even thing
cuz Joe I know man because even two
people who are on the left that looks
like you're just begging for the mods
like the real problem is she never did
deny what Tulsi said and she can't oh
you're about record and how terrible her
record the record was awful if
absolutely what she did with schools is
the most disgusting thing yes single
moms with jail if their kids didn't go
to school and she joked around about it
at these meetings she joked around about
it and did in conferences you know about
how she cleaned it up and she just had
cops knocking on the door hahaha
you know it was bad disturbing yeah what
was even worse is there was somebody who
was found not guilty on something they
were wrongfully imprisoned found not
guilty on something when I came
and then Kemal Harris didn't let him out
and kept him in on the technicality and
said all your paperwork wasn't filed in
the proper time circle whatever was on
purpose herself she yes yes this is the
story that broke and why why did she do
that I don't know I have no idea but
this is one of the things that you know
Tulsi was shining a spotlight on one of
the things that tell us he said which
they use them for cheap labor for the
state of California and she didn't deny
any of that she because her record is
abysmal on this stuff I mean there's no
there's nothing that she got to this
prominent position without any of that
being exposed and Tulsi exposed it just
like click turn the lights on well look
at the Steve minuchin thing this is one
that we've known for a while so Steve
minuchin was part of Goldman Sachs he
was also the head of one West Bank here
in California and what happened was they
were during the subprime mortgage crisis
in the Great Recession they were
illegally foreclosing on people early
and kicking them out of their homes in
violation of the law and so Kamla Harris
uh you know it was recommended by her
own office you got to prosecute this guy
look at what he's doing she didn't do it
why because he's a big Democratic to her
and he was giving money to Democrats at
the time now by the way just in case
anybody thinks oh this is just a
partisan issue and only the Democrats
are bad
Steve minuchin is in the Trump
administration yeah he's hilarious so
it's a weak club and you ain't in it is
the point to steal from George Carlin
remember when her his wife was taking
all these [ __ ] Instagram photos with
all the [ __ ] she had on private jets and
stuff they look like Bond villains bro
he's got gloves on holding money with
the gloves the [ __ ] wears those gloves
that go down to your elbows if you look
at villains yeah thank you come on she's
holding up money she probably feels
dirty holding up ones you but the fact
the fact that she's wearing those
goddamn gloves like oh my god and in the
fact that she looks like she should be
[ __ ] a football player she should be
[ __ ] these got a gazillion dollars
that's why kind of hilarious right when
you look at the disparity in beauty well
these are the codis are the [ __ ] who
really run the economy goldman sachs
really runs the economy goldman sachs it
was proven that they committed fraud at
a massive level what they would do is
i'm gonna order us a coffee you'd like
one of them sure I'll take one wrong
with
coffee machine hold on a second okay so
I'm Blaine so anyway Steve minuchin
Steve minuchin and Goldman Sachs it was
found that in the lead-up to the
subprime mortgage crisis in the Great
Recession here's what they would do Joe
they would sell to unsuspecting clients
these packages these packages of
subprime mortgages but they were rated
triple-a and they would sell them these
packages saying hey man listen this is a
great long-term investment it's safe
you're gonna make a lot of money at the
same time goldman sachs was doing that
they would turn around and bet on those
packages that they just sold as if they
were awesome they would bet on those
packages to fail so that's fraud they
were making money in two different ways
I'm gonna sell you the package and make
money
okay and then on the other hand I'm
gonna bet on this same package I just
sold you to fail that's like a car
salesman saying oh I'm gonna sell you
this car and this car works wonderfully
everything's using car amazing car
tremendous car the most unbelievable car
really so it's like angers down salesman
doing that Joe and then the salesman
also betting his buddy that that car is
gonna break down before it gets that a
lot
right so these are criminals Joe and the
thing is it's Democrats and Republicans
who are propping them up the Wall Street
bailout cost 14 trillion dollars why is
it we could spend money on that but we
can't have an infrastructure deal that
gives our country an a-plus
infrastructure I want to have the number
one infrastructure in the world you had
Elon Musk on not too long ago he's
working on this thing called the
Hyperloop yeah the Hyperloop is supposed
to be the future of travel where you
kind of get in a pod and it's vacuum
power too you can go from New York to LA
in like three hours or whatever it is on
the ground I want why don't we have that
everywhere in this country why don't we
have bridges that are fixed why don't we
have awesome roads why can't we go to
airports and feel national pride and say
this airports absolutely beautiful
[Applause]